voters in the united kingdom have voted
to leave the European Union is this
victory brings down this failed project
leads us to a Europe of sovereign
nation-states it's a major blow to
European political and economic
integration and a huge embarrassment for
British Prime Minister David Cameron
Britain is better off inside the EU than
out on our own at the heart of that is
the single market 500 million customers
on our doorstep a source of so many jobs
so much trade and such a wealth of
opportunity for our young people
Britain's exit or the brexit as it's
called will have huge implications for
the British economy the EU functions as
a single integrated economy kind of like
the United States and now that Britain
is out regulations could make it harder
to move goods across the English Channel
lots of multinational corporations have
their headquarters in London but now
they might find that it makes more sense
to have their European headquarters in
the European Union which could lead to
job losses in Britain the EU also allows
for the free movement of people within
its member states which means that any
EU citizen can live and work in any
other EU country without a visa and the
UK's high employment rate has drawn
migrants from poorer countries in the EU
like Poland in Lithuania but many in
Britain resent these migrants and that
resentment was a key driving force in
the decision of for Britain to leave the
European Union so now the print is out
nobody really knows what's going to
happen to all those EU migrants so what
comes next a long negotiation between
the UK and the EU member states where
they have to hash out issues like trade
tariffs agriculture immigration and a
whole host of other issues nobody really
knows what this means for the other EU
countries they could rally together and
push for even more integration or some
countries could look at Britain and say
we should get out too but one thing is
clear
Britain's exit is a huge blow to the
dream of a united Europe